Charlie it's Oh Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool
hello everyone if you're a youtuber have
you ever started doing a video without
any plan to your video at all I know
most people usually like to plan out
what they're going to say in their video
but today I haven't the faintest clue
what I'm going to talk about today no I
know what I'm gonna do so this should be
interesting
or boring one of the two I'd love to say
I think this hat is awesome
but the thing is it's really
uncomfortable this isn't gonna work is
it this brilliant that'll work
we've actually got somebody working on
our house at the moment
and I think he's just outside he
probably thinks I'm a serious weirdo if
I don't get out my guitar very often
doing
[Music]
I think it's broken
so my trip down to my dad's house is
going pretty good
my family are actually at the beach of
the moment bike really couldn't be
bothered to go I mean I woke up at
lunchtime and they were all you know
already packed and ready to go and I was
just kind of like looking through the
night look into the light this would be
a lot scarier at nighttime there I sent
a message to the wine cone today I love
his videos and I want to chat to him
because he seems like a really cool
person but I didn't know how to ask him
that without sending really really lame
[Music]
he probably won't respond and I don't
blame him to be honest
can you tell I'm bored I think you can
this really is the definition of Charlie
randomness isn't it I mean it's
completely random anything could happen
well probably not anything there was a
wide range of things that could happen
maybe I don't know I completely forgot
to tell you guys that I bought on your
webcam but you probably worked that out
already
so there's no point in going into it is
a no my lack of broadband is getting
really annoying the ironic thing is my
dad actually works for BT so why we
still have dial-up is a mystery to me
but whatever oh my god that looks so
weird
can I see a magic trick with this
elastic band on those two fingers I'm
going to put my fingers down and
hopefully I'm lucky the elastic bands
should jump to the other thing is magic
I was never any good at magic
somebody has to get this torch away from
me or I am going to eat it
I really am that bored I think I'm just
going to give up I don't even know if
this is gonna be able loaded or not
maybe if it looks funny and editing I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I already have
no idea
[Music]
see you next time
you
wait a minute are you saying you are
actually bothered to watch the whole
thing to the end good I'm glad to have
hardcore fans like you good on you
see ya